buenas noches los planes de navidad para
por lo menos 38 millones de personas
aquí en inglaterra han sido cancelados
esto vos lo dices tras el anuncio del
primer ministro el aumento de los casos
y la aparición de un nuevo tipo de kobe
que es hasta 77 por ciento más
contagioso dicen los expertos y el
gobierno sin embargo que no hay certeza
de que este nuevo tipo de kobe que está
aquí en la zona de londres en el list en
el este y en el sureste del país no sea
más letal pero por supuesto el gobierno
todavía y las autoridades médicas no
cuentan con todos los datos pero ya ha
sido informada la organización mundial
de la salud sobre este nuevo tipo de
virus las medidas el gobierno ha creado
una extra tipo de restricciones que
aplica como lo dices para estas zonas
que son muchísimo más drásticas es decir
prácticamente el gobierno pide que no se
salga de la casa bajo ninguna
circunstancia salvo quienes tienen que
salir a trabajar o alguna emergencia
médica los locales comerciales estarán
cerrados los no esenciales también
ignacio lugares de placer los
restaurantes vienen siendo cerrados hace
varios días no se puede viajar a nivel
internacional en el caso del resto del
país podrán unirse hasta tres casas
distintas solo para la fiesta de navidad
solo el 25 de diciembre tampoco se
espera que haya relajación en estas
reglas para las fiestas de fin de año
así que estas son las nuevas medidas que
el gobierno ha anunciado que empiezan a
regir a primera hora de este domingo